please hold on this train is departing
[Music]
try your hands tied together
[Music]
what the hell are you doing slow down
hello howard kendra i've been watching
the coverage
the tanker truck strange it was there on
the one night
that something else would go wrong with
the train
were you kendra mali i'm the lead crash
investigator
how many people early reports are 60
dead
an oil tanker this size it should be no
match for a 600 ton train
do you think someone killed all these
people on purpose ellen hunter fbi your
crash just became my crime scene
lucas what is it i saw that man he
killed
one the software had nothing to do with
the crash
what are we trying to pin this on me now
was the marshall transporting a federal
prisoner
the fbi put me on that train she's
running for governor now
you did this for folks you mess with me
i messed back
wait wait what's what's that i'd like to
discuss
the terms of my cooperation someone's
referred to that to any extent to stop
us from finding the truth let's find
this guy let's move
who else had the information
our job here is to find out why the
train crashed and i will pin this on
whoever is responsible
you